UN member states will consider a new
Russian-led treaty on cybercrime.
Having hacked US infrastructure, interfered
in US elections, and cracked down on its own
cyberspace with authoritarian zeal, the Russian
government knows the subject well. Nonetheless,
despite its abysmal record, Moscow’s efforts
to rewrite global cybercrime regulations
have already been greeted with
some initial success at the UN.
These developments are part of a larger
trend of Russia coopting UN cyber norms,
together with China. In January,
the two nations attempted to hijack the
UN’s International Telecommunication Union,
which determines the rules of internet governance,
to make the web more autocrat-friendly.
Moscow and Beijing have already turned the
internet into a tool for domestic repression.
Allowing them to dictate the rules
for the rest of the world is absurd.
The US must rally its allies to stop autocrats’
push to rewrite the rules of cyberspace,
and curb Russia and China’s
influence in the UN more broadly.
Who do you think should govern the
internet? Let us know in our poll.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.